Have you ever looked at your agent
execution and asked yourself the
question, why did it do that?
What if it had done a different thing?
Would it have been cheaper? Would it
have been faster?
Well, you can do all these things
if your agents have a save button.
We've had the save button for documents
for
decades now. Since the 1980s, people
have been used to pressing control S,
command S
uh or auto saving while you're working
to have a persistent state.
But agents, they don't have that today.
The only thing we have which is closest
is a trace. A trace gives you the
emitted telemetry data of how an agent
calls tools in the input and output of
that state. Now, while this is a good
start, it is actually very disconnected
from the runtime in which these agents
actually execute. So, all the variables
that are in state, all the file system
that is in in flight, um the decisions
that it makes in the code, uh the actual
code itself,
all of that is lost and it is
only stamped as a read-only trace by the
end, which is sitting in another tool
far away from where the actual code is.
And I think this is what's missing today
in the industry is that we don't have a
clear connection between the
observability
spans that are emitted with Odel and the
execution.
And maybe at this point you might be
wondering, but why even bother? Why do I
need to have a save button?
Well, save allows you to replay. You can
go back in history and ask the what if
question.
What are the types of questions you
might want to ask? Well, you might want
to swap the model. Maybe you use a an
open-source model that is cheaper.
Maybe you mock a tool and you override
the what it returns. Maybe you degrade
it intentionally to see what would
happen if things are wrong.
And
these sorts of questions are only
possible if you have that state.
And
there is a category of the stack
emerging which actually allows that. And
this sit on top of the harness
sit on top of the frameworks that allow
you to create agents.
And put a durable runtime below that. Um
and augments the traces that are emitted
with actually the code execution and the
things that are around it to actually
complete the state of this of the of the
system.
And the good news is that
once you have such a system
in production, you already have the
information you need to ask those
questions that are relevant to making
your system better,
cheaper, and faster.
Production already has the traces. It
already has these state checkpoints
ideally from the runtime that can allow
you to go back in time and ask those
questions. For example, let's take an
agent example which does a customer
resolution
and refunds after a chargeback dispute.
Well, you can then see if the order
status is changing languages or whether
the request should have been escalated
or maybe a smaller model would have
handled it if the runtime is
checkpointing each of the state as it
goes along.
Almost like an auto save, a command S, a
control S in your agent.
And once you have that, you can even
close the loop.
Uh this conference is all about loops.
So, this is nothing different. You have
a cohort of runs that you think
maybe matter because maybe they're too
expensive, they took too long. You
replay a change, you diff it, you see
what would have happened when you have
the baseline, which you know what
happened in the first place, and then
you decide and you route and you ship
back.
That's closing the loop on your e-vals.
It's It's It's basically evaluating
using your production traces.
So,
it's basically evaluating using your
production checkpoints.
So, checkpoint replay diff decide. And
this is really the methodology that that
I've seen and I've seen others do,
uh which has really scaled.
For example, DoorDash. DoorDash has
a a blog post on the 1st of June where
they talk about having a simulated
environment where they replayed customer
bots. And they've done what-if scenarios
and seeing how they could have made it
better. And where And where it used to
take them hours and hours to to do this,
now they've reduced it to 5 minutes
uh with hundreds of simulations, have
90% less hallucinations, and they're
still two points within what they've
seen in production. So, the simulations
are pretty good because they're grounded
in what's already happened.
So,
we're going to just walk through this um
in an example, and we're going to see
how this works.
Uh for this demo, we're going to be
using a tool called Kitaru. Kitaru is a
very new tool that is launched by the
team at uh ZenML. ZenML is has been
around for many years and is a player in
the orchestration space. I'm one of the
co-founders.
And Kitaru is something we've launched
recently, which allows you to have a
runtime layer below your harness layer,
and also connect to your traces.
Um and do all the checkpointing that we
were just talking about and then running
replay scenarios.
So, you can see here I have all of my I
have a support uh agent which looks at
my customer requests and escalates it
when it needs to to humans.
You can see various things as you might
expect. Um, every tool call
uh can see a timeline view if I wanted.
And here the difference is that if I if
I click on a particular
um
um checkpoint like a tool call, I can
see
the configuration, where it ran, uh the
code it it took um and the artifacts
which came in and out of it.
Um and this combination of code and the
artifacts that it created and the
environment in which it ran in, whether
it was a Docker image or a sandbox,
those are all snapshotted in state here
between the checkpoints.
And you can see that here in this
particular example, there was a few tool
calls every time it went to the LLM, and
I can actually see um you know, how long
it took.
But imagine I wanted to do something
different. Imagine I wanted to change
the model if I maybe at this point
I wanted to use a cheaper model. Would
it have done the same stuff afterwards?
So,
to do this in Kitaro, it's quite easy.
All you have to do
Now, to do this in Kitaro is quite easy.
All you have to do is you have to
take your execution and replay it at a
particular point.
So, I'm just going to copy this over
and I'm going to put it in my terminal
and see what happens.
So, here what I'm doing is essentially I
am saying, "Okay, after this particular
tool call,
change the model to GPT-5 Nano, which is
obviously a bit cheaper." Um and then
what's going to happen here
is
there's going to be a new execution
that's launched
from 71
and you can see the first three
checkpoints are skipped. So, they're all
skipped because
Kitaro already has the state of all the
checkpoints before that. All it needs to
do is just change this particular
checkpoint and then execute start
executing from here. And this is really
cool because now I can see what would
have happened in this scenario if there
was a cheaper model. So this looks
pretty similar to me, but
what if I had wanted to do a even
different change? What if I wanted to
mock a tool or or or if I wanted to
change a tool call?
Well, in order to do that,
you can mock up for example the lookup
policy tool.
And here it's also very easy. I can just
go back here.
Replay. And this time, rather than
changing the model, I am changing the
lookup policy. And I'm mocking it with
another function
in my code base,
which returns a different lookup policy.
And I'm just trying to understand if the
policy had changed, what would have
happened. This time I'm holding the
model constant. Now,
the interesting thing here is that
because I have the code, it's very easy
for me to do tool calls and to change
these particular things and do more
experiments than I would have had if I
was completely disconnected from the
code base.
And here you can see that the code base
is a little bit different, so I see my
logs here.
They look a little bit different.
And here you can see that I got a
slightly different artifact maybe from
the tool call, and it published the
thing. So now again, I have three runs.
I have the original run and I have the
two replays. Now, what if I wanted to
see them side by side, right? So Kitaro
actually has this very handy diff
command that lets me give an original ID
of an execution
and then allows me
on the other side to actually see them
side by side. So I can see what
happened.
So there's a few warnings here
about some artifacts, but in a second
it will go and give me a URL.
I can copy this URL and I can actually
put it directly here.
And now I have a very nice
um
comparison of the original and the two
forks.
Um I can see a bunch of things here, but
I think what's really interesting is
this view. So, in this view, you can see
that the first part of the the baseline
is the same, right? So, these things
were skipped. They were exactly as it
is. The state is exactly where it was.
Um but now, right after that, in the
third replay, it's a little bit
different, right? The tool call happened
a bit differently because we used a
different policy, and then something
changed after here.
Um here, it took a little bit longer.
And you can really start looking at the
final result. And if I click on the
final result, I can actually see the
artifacts side by side. I can see what
decision um it actually ended up making.
So, you can see that it uh here, it
restricted the count charge. Here, it
also restricted it. Here, it also
restricted it. In the first two, it
actually needs review. In the third,
because we changed the policy, it's safe
to answer. So, this might or might not
be good in your scenario, but if is this
is what you expected to see? Well,
maybe.
Because the these two were cheaper at
the end of the day. For for for the
number of tokens consumed, uh they were
cheaper.
Input and output. And you can see a
bunch of detail here
uh in the in the UI, which might be
useful for these
for these analyses.
Okay, but this is just one point, right?
What if I wanted to do this across a
cohort? What if I wanted to have a bunch
of runs, right? Which actually um
maybe sorted by cost. So, maybe I took
all of my expensive ones. Then I wanted
to do one change across the entire
cohort. So, change the change all the
tool calls that happened
uh that happened for this particular set
of configurations across the cohort. Or
change the model itself
um and use a cheaper model across the
cohort. So, this gives me a bigger
distribution of information and replays
that I can use.
Um and now, I can just this.
Um, and the way you would replay it is
you can use the replay mini command
where you actually
um, start from a particular point and
you do the same as you did before just
across the cohort.
Um, this is going to take a while, so
I'm not going to do it now. But once you
execute it, in this particular case, I
just emitted it to JSON, so I have
a very nice, uh, JSON
here, and this JSON gives me a bunch of
things. So, this is a bit hard to do the
UI, right? So, there's a lot of things
going on. You can't just do the many,
many, many comparisons here.
Um, but what you could do, and what I
love to do personally, is use the Kitaru
MCP server.
And here what you do is you can just
say, "Hey, read this
you read this JSON report and do an
analysis
on what you think I should be doing
across the cohort."
And I think this is what What is really
important is to be using agents and LLMs
to analyze these cohorts across a
plethora of data because at some point
uh, I mean, 10 is probably easy to do,
but what if you have thousands?
Um, and doing thousands and thousands is
hard, and this is where skills and MCP
servers get really relevant and having
the runtime be queryable and go into
your execution and fetch the artifacts
is very important.
So, it's going to be
it's going to be uh, doing a lot of
things. So, it's it's it's trying to,
you know, um, run an analysis around
these decisions and it's going to flag
any um, red flags that that happen.
So.
While this is going on, um,
maybe we can go back and continue our
presentation. So,
um,
Here you can see, yeah. Yes, if you
change the model, it can get very cheap.
And of course, you don't want to do it
across just one sample, but across many
because then you can see a bigger
variation. I think one thing which is
important here is and
to be very honest is that while we've
been doing it this with our users and
customers, what I've personally seen is
that
having a naive model swap usually or
often times doesn't work. So just
changing for example to a cheaper model
and just looking at the cost one single
dimensionally, obviously it could be
that you're you're spending a lot less
money, but what happens if your support
board is not resolving the requests,
right? So this is a study from
BrainTrust. Excellent study where they
actually looked at that and they saw
that there could be a false economy if
you do a naive model swap because it
might look on paper that you're faster
and you're cheaper, but at the end of
the day you have to look at the value
created, right? So it's a trade-off
between how much money you want to spend
and and yeah, the result.
And also, if you look at the towel
bench,
what we must understand is that a model
that passes 60% of the time is only
self-consistent about a quarter of the
time. So which basically means that one
replay is just an anecdote
and having a cohort
analysis is way way way better.
Um
and because then you can really see
across a population and across scale
what would have happened
not just looking at one estimate.
This can get very expensive of course
and this is where you have to be really
smart about what you replay and have
tooling that really helps you.
And this you can really bake into your
production process as well, right? So
again,
if you if you take a step back and look
at the playbook, you can start from real
runs,
not synthetic, but real runs, real
production
uh
state.
Build cohorts that matter.
Um maybe take the expensive ones, maybe
take the long ones, maybe take the risky
ones.
Um never ship anything by just replaying
one or two things.
Um and just do this at scale and uh
ship, route, and hold, and try to
automate that loop as much as possible.
Maybe there's an agent that's doing that
for you. Um that's even better.
But you just have a human in the loop at
the end.
Now, let's see where our cohort analysis
has gotten us.
Okay, so we're done. So, the verdict is
don't ship. So, even though it looked
like from a single replay that it was
cheaper to do and we reached the same
result, across a bunch of those support
cases, you actually saw that our agent
concludes that you shouldn't be using a
cheaper model in this particular case
for your data.
But this might be different for your
data.
In conclusion,
um
if you want to be replaying
your agent executions and answering the
questions
what if
I had done something different while
designing this agent or what if the
agent could be driven to do something
different?
Well, you can do this if you model your
agent
with your harness in a runtime that can
checkpoint state
and is able to replay that state from
code with different scenarios.
If you want to use Guitar Ru, the the
the tool that I showed that allows you
to do it,
um you can scan the repo. It's open
source, free to use, and uh we'd
appreciate the feedback and love.
Thank you so much, and see you guys on
the next one.